hello everyone and welcome to a real
sunday improver this is a really wild
one and a lot of you have already
suggested this to me it's from
yesterday's leeches titled arena and
it's magnus carlsen versus cloud9 andrew
tang
also known as the penguin unleaches
although this was played on his
c9 c9 c9 c9 c9 c9 c9 account
but that out of the way it's a really
really an impressive game so
i hope you guys enjoy it is a bullet
game but we always mention these guys
are so strong that even in that
one minute per player they can create uh
well yeah beauty such as this one
so without further ado let's check it
out magnus has the white pieces in this
game and he opens with
e4 andrew goes for e6 so the french
defense is on the board
we have d4 d5 and e5 now magnus goes for
the advanced variation of the french
now uh there are a lot of very popular
moves here like
knight e7 c5 bishop d7 pretty much any
move
but the move and replace knights to d7
is somewhat a rare one
uh so let's see how magnus deals with is
basically preparing
preparing c5 so knight to f3 we have c5
and
c3 now magnus strengthens the center
here and only now
knight to e7 we have bishop to d3
just nicely continuing development and
knight to c6
now we have castles and now queen to b6
uh
somewhat hindering the development of
the dark square bishop as the b2 pawn
will become a target and there's also a
lot of pressure on this d4 pawn
so here we have bishop back to c2 now
the queen also helps out with the
defense of this pawn
and bishop to e7 andrew now ready to
castle we have
a3 and h6 taking away the g5 square from
white's pieces
and now magnus strikes on the queen side
with
b4 so c captures on d4 we have c
captures and now a5 and this position
actually has been
reached in the 12th german championship
uh
in 1948 between wilhelm ernst and paul
trega
and the game ended in draw but that game
continued by b
captures on a5 but here magnus uh
figures out a new idea and it's really a
refreshing one he plays
b5 now this is the absolute top move uh
recommended by the engine so i don't
know if magnus
started this line or is this some sort
of a bullet idea or
was it was it the bullet preparation but
it's a very exciting one because you're
you're asking black to move the knight
and black of course not
very interested in moving the knight
because then you just continue
developing
you cemented this pawn on b5 and it's
just uh it's just a better position
for white so here uh andrew accepts the
pawn sacrifice and now
white gets a lot of development in so
knight to c3
attacking the queen queen to b6 and now
rook to b1
another free move for that well not for
you it cost one pawn
uh queen to d8 and now knight to b5 and
okay
uh white grabbed a lot of space but
black is up a pawn so here
knight to b6 preparing to shift the
knight over to c4
which will put a lot of pressure on this
a3 pawn
uh we bishop the e3 developing and
defending the the central d4 pawn and
knight to c for pawn as as we already
mentioned
knights to d2 by magnus attacking the
knight here and here andrew could play
uh
a safe move but he decides to grab the
yet another pawn and here he goes knight
captures on a3
and this is again the absolute best move
recommended by the engine so here
andrew is very happy with himself we
have captures on a3 bishop captures and
here
magnus needs to figure out what he's
doing uh because he's down two pawns
andrew now has two past pawns on the
queen side
and if those spawns start marching
forward it's going to be very very
difficult to stop them
however andrew's king is also in the
center of the board so queen to g4
threatening to capture on g7 and you
can't really castle here those bishops
are really really annoying
uh if you castle here it just loses on
the spot just bishop captures on h6 and
now you you really don't have a move if
you play some like g6 just bishop
captures on g6
and you're very very quickly getting
checkmated so
uh instead after queen to g4 we have
king to f8 getting the king to a bit of
a safer square guarding
the g7 pawn and now you don't have to
worry about bishop captures anything
so here we have f4 by magnus he wants to
play f5 capture here open up
the f file for the rook of course we
have bishop back to b4
uh and now f5 magnus continues pushing
we have queen the e8 uh not not the
greatest of moves here
you you just trade for example captures
captures captures and captures and yes
white has a lot of pressure here but
black should be able to hold this after
queen to e7
it's not the the most pleasant position
but you really
uh don't don't have all that many
worries here and you're still up
material
however andrew for some reason uh went
queen to e8 not for some reason it's a
bullet game so sometimes you see ghosts
sometimes
the ghosts are there sometimes they
aren't there but okay queen to e8 adding
another defender to the pawn here
and now comes f6 by magnus and this is a
problem because queen captures on g7
will be checkmate now
so andrew has to play something he goes
g6 and now
knight to f3 waiting with some ideas
like bishop captures and g6 maybe it's a
bit too early for that
and like i said if you don't really have
a clear sight of what you're doing you
don't want to
overdo it there will not be a lot of
time to calculate this so knight to f3
preparing to bring another attacker into
the game and now
h5 pushing the queen back queen to f4
and now comes a4 now andrew says all
right everything is perfectly fine on
the king side or even if it's not i
don't have time to calculate
i'm just going to push my past pawn to
victory so
knight the g5 by magnus now going for
some other weaknesses here and a3 now
andrew continues pushing the pass pawn
we have rook to b3
and a2 now uh magnus blocks the pass
pawn
rook to a1 and now b5 now andrew starts
pushing the other
the other past pawn with bishop to d3
magnus attacks it and now rook to a5
defending that pawn and now queen to f2
attacking the a2 pawn and here magnus
says all right now i'm going to capture
this pawn and there really isn't
anything you can do about this
so bishop to d7 and magnus just grabs it
here if you had a bit more time you
wouldn't really go after this pawn but
whenever i'm covering a bullet game and
i say you know if
this is better or this is better this is
if you had more time of course you don't
you're not expected to
find any of this in a bullet game but
okay just for your
fun queen to c2 really puts a lot of
pressure on this g6 pawn
and you you can always capture this
there is really no rush in doing this
but okay rook captures an a2 with queen
the a8 now
doubling up on the a file preparing rook
captures on a2 so of course you have to
capture
or you can double up also possible but
okay here magnus captured we have queen
captures on a5
and now rook back to b1 uh covering the
the back rank we have
king to g8 uh probably with the idea of
freeing up the f8 square for the bishop
if needed uh and here well you could go
for the immediate bishop captures on g6
this is in the game uh for the entire
time it's uh
what if black plays bishop to ea then
you're just going to have to calculate
some more it's a bullet game you don't
have all that
all that much time of course andrew is
not just going to capture and ally with
something like f7
king f8 queen f6 and it's a practical
game over if rook h6 just
just knight captures with check you pick
up this rook with checks so this
black's position just falls apart uh but
of course if you don't see it all the
way then you're just going to waste time
so here magnus plays
h4 we have king back to f8 sort of a
well i guess this was a waiting game
maneuver
and only now magnus goes for bishop
captures on g6
uh we have f captures on g6 not much you
can do here and now magnus goes for
f7 again a bit maybe a bit too soon
maybe a move like
queen to c2 would have been a little bit
more precise but okay
as like i said this is bullet so this uh
f7 preparing queen to f6
and now andrew has to prevent queen to
f6 so bishop to e7
guarding the f6 square and queen to f4
now
uh adding another defender to this pawn
here also
uh keeping an eye on that h6 square if
rook to h6 for some reason then you can
go for some sacrifices not like that
and you know win some material and here
you have to go a kink to g7 this is
actually the way to go
point is that you have to over protect
both f6 and f8 for example if the rook
comes to f1 then you bring the queen
over here and everything is nicely
protected
not not a lot to worry about however
andrew played knight to d8 here
and this will uh prove to be a bit too
difficult to defend here
magnus played rook to f1 he brought
another piece into the attack
and now it doesn't really matter what
black plays andrew played queen to c3
but now it's actually a forced
checkmate in four so feel free to pause
the video here and
improve your own sunday while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding the
peace slash queen sacrifice not slash
queen a peace and queen sacrifice and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's
knights the h7 with check this is what
we start with
first we give up the knight and it
doesn't help if you uh avoid it because
if you play king g7 then the rook no
longer guards the h6 square we put a
knight on h7 so queen to h6 will just be
checkmate
so after knight to h7 check you have to
capture it which andrew did
now comes queen to h6 check now we
sacrifice the queen because all of these
squares are covered the king cannot go
here
and if there's a check along the dark
squares well that's basically checkmate
so
uh you can't really do anything you
can't even block because then just queen
h
queen h8 check rook jade queen captures
and g8 will be checkmate
or even pawn captures that's a bit
cooler because there's now a double
check here two queens are on the board
so you could also do that so however
after queen to h6 check
andrew captured it you know just uh to
play the game uh all the way and
after bishop captures on h6 uh it was in
this position that the game
ended on move 40 because now yeah it's
uh well it's checkmated the
the pawn covers the g8 and the e8
squares and the bishop delivers this
uh beautiful beautiful checkmate that
improved all of ours
all of our sundays uh so uh that's the
game i hope you guys
enjoyed it i received really a lot of
suggestions for this one so i knew it
was a great one and uh
whenever i receive a magnus versus
andrew game i know it's
it's going to be a wild one and uh
there's a link to this uh
game in the description below so if you
want to check it out or analyze yourself
on leeches do check it out it was from
the alicia's title arena i don't know if
i've mentioned it
uh magnus won the arena and he donated
uh the 750
750 back uh to be added to the prize for
the next leeches titled arena
and also if you guys enjoy games like
these short games where you know a lot
of things
crazy things happen uh i will put uh
some four links in the description below
to some previous games that magnus
played in the league's title the
arena so do check that out as well uh if
you know
if you don't really have all that much
to do on a sunday maybe if it's raining
outside or i don't know like it's
raining here like
crazy for for the past week uh so yeah
once again uh thank you guys i hope you
enjoyed it
and uh i would like to thank axel verma
carlos chavez for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh and by whatever i mean the candidates
tournament uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your sunday